[Music]
foreign
as powerful as he may be is an
omnipotent he can still be harmed
injured and also killed unfortunately
but that's what makes for a good
character and I guide you at that it
does take a lot to put him down though
and over the years he has been killed in
various ways so here in this video we
will showcase all the 10 times Godzilla
has died including his variance so let's
get to it number one the 1954 original
in the Cinematic debut of the iconic
Godzilla in the year 1954 the Colossal
kaju despite his devastating Rampage and
widespread destruction ultimately met
his demise the demise of Godzilla was a
result of the ingenious creation known
as the oxygen Destroyer a formidable
weapon specially designed for
eradicating oxygen from water upon
contact this remarkable chemical
compound has the Sinister ability to
transform the one sustaining aquatic
environment into a corrosive and lethal
trap the consequences were catastrophic
as living organisms submerged in this
rapidly deoxygenated environment met a
grim fate including Godzilla and the
flesh gets liquefied by the corrosive
Waters
number two the heisei Godzilla's death
this G-Man after his long years of
battling monsters also died in his last
movie this was caused by a nuclear
meltdown in its own body driven by the
overwhelming accumulation of radiation
within his body a result of exposure
from volcanic eruptions and radiation
deposits as a result Godzilla
superheated his body temperature Rose to
unprecedented levels and rendering him
an imminent threat to the planet itself
his meltdown was so intense that waves
of nuclear pulses were emitted after
short durations which also proved fatal
to the Monstrous Destroyer his arch
enemy and in the end with the help of
the Frieza weapons of humanity his death
didn't result in the destruction of the
earth thankfully in fact it became a
Revival process for a dead Godzilla
Junior
number three the death of space Godzilla
so space Godzilla was a clone of the
G-Man a result of Godzilla's cells being
flung into space by Mothra anyway when
space Godzilla matured and came back to
Earth he tried to assert dominance over
his progenitor after a series of battles
with a Mecca called moguera also joining
in and being knocked out Godzilla
Unleashed his most deadly attack he used
his red spiral heat tray an upgrade over
the standard atomic breath he used it
several times at his enemy and space
Godzilla slowly died as a result and
just like the other Kaiju called
biolante which was also a sort of a
Godzilla hybrid space Godzilla which is
more like a Godzilla than any other
exploded into spores when he was finally
destroyed
number four the death of TriStar
Godzilla this Godzilla was weak as
to be honest anyway in the movie a plan
was devised by the US military to lure
him into the Brooklyn Bridge in New York
where he could be more easily targeted
by the military after destroying the
nest in Madison Square Garden Godzilla
was enraged and chased after what he
deemed to be responsible for the baby's
deaths Godzilla in his Pursuit leaped
into the bridge but his immense size and
weight caused him to become ensnared in
the suspension cables with a colossal
creature trapped and immobilized three
F-18 Hornets flew overhead and Unleashed
a Relentless barrage of Firepower and
missiles upon the stationary Master the
explosions and Firepower caused Godzilla
to die stuck in the bridge
number five cyber zilla's death so cyber
Godzilla was born from the remnants of
the original Tri-Stack Godzilla that
perished in New York City in 1998. after
the creature's demise its remains were
transported to a military facility for
scientific examination however the base
was seized by the Leviathan aliens who
possessed advanced technology they
transformed the lifeless Godzilla into a
cybernetic entity entirely under their
command now a puppet of the aliens he
was to eliminate the human team which
posed a threat to the aliens plans but a
second Zilla stepped in and fought each
other culminating in the moment when
Godzilla tackled cyber Godzilla into the
water in this final struggle Godzilla
managed to dismantle cyber Godzilla's
internal mechanisms ultimately leading
to his demise
number six the death of gmk Godzilla so
unlike other interpretations of the
character this Godzilla is a
supernatural entity inhabited by the
Restless Souls of those killed in the
Pacific Theater during World War II
Godzilla sought revenge against Japan
for forgetting and ignoring the past and
came a show to punish the nation by
obliterating its cities but he was
counted by the three Guardian spirits of
Japan who were Ghidorah Mothra and
Baragon however Godzilla easily defeated
all three monsters but their efforts
exploited a weakness in Godzilla that
the jsdf the Defense Forces of Japan
used to finally defeat him by sending a
missile right down his throat killing
him from the inside however even after
Godzilla's body was destroyed his heart
was left behind continuously beating on
the sea floor
number 7 the death of Godzilla singular
point so his Origins firstly are
mysterious regarded in nigashio Legend
as the same Master Gojira Godzilla was
prophesied to bring the end of the world
when the Seas would stay in red this
Godzilla had four forms and was
hyper-evolving due to a
trans-dimensional element called the
archetype due to this Godzilla embodied
that strange matters intrinsic nature to
persist and exist therefore he always
evolved against attacks to a point where
virtually nothing could hurt him however
there was a sort of an antidote to this
trans-dimensional archetype and it was
in the form of a code called the
orthogonal diagonalizer which was
activated by Jet Jaguar In the Heat of
battle destroying itself and caused
Godzilla to die and disappear and his
archetype to become blue crystals spread
all over Tokyo
number 8 the death of titanus Gojira as
Dagon so seen in the beginning of
Godzilla 2014 belonging to the same
Titans gojiro species as Godzilla within
the master verse daegon shared a
multitude of physical characteristics
with his iconic counterpart so in a
significant historical event dating back
to 1100 BC Dagon became embroiled in a
Fierce and consequential battle with a
formidable parasitic entity known as the
muto Prime this epic encounter had
far-reaching consequences for both these
colossal beings Prime implanted her eggs
into the gojira's stomach lining and
Dagon was left weakened and his demise
was then sealed slowly but steadily
these parasitic acts just stated with a
dagon's colossal frame fitting
voraciously on his nuclear-rich blood
therefore killing him and these two
parasitic spores grew up to be the male
and the female Muto seen in 2014.
number nine the death of Godzilla
philius so seen in the first installment
of the anime Trilogy of Godzilla philius
was formed from the cells that divided
from Godzilla Earth during the 20 000
years he ruled over the planet Godzilla
Affiliates grew to a height of 50 meters
or 165 feet tall mistaking him for the
larger Godzilla Earth the humans and
Aliens engage in a fight with it
discovering a weakness in the process
and that is his em Shield that is
produced by an organ located in his
dorsal plates if the organ is targeted
and destroyed at a moment where the
shield is not deployed The Shield will
be disabled until the organ regenerates
and acting this plan they were able to
overload phyllis's body with his own
energy effectively exploding the
Godzilla into bits and pieces
and number 10 the death of shin Godzilla
a year so to be clear Shin Godzilla
isn't actually dead but in a death-like
state which is why we decide to put him
here in this list as the last entry so
Shin Godzilla was shown to be the
epitome of evolution and was followed by
a nuclear organ system rapidly evolving
to counter every Challenge and hardship
however due to this nuclear system he
had to regularly shut down to allow his
body to cool down from the heat
generated from inside and this is how
Japan counted him and they believed that
a blood coagulant would interrupt
Godzilla's blood cooling system causing
him to perform a reactor scram to stay
alive and freeze solid so Against All
Odds during his Dorman State they were
able to pump in the liquid and froze his
entire body leaving Shin Godzilla in a
state of deathless lumber and so those
are all 10 Godzilla deaths explored here
in this video so I hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do hit the like
button for support and subscribe but
most of all smash the Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel take care fam